this is how i stay so young looking beef
steamed
hey i'm she here i'm a recipe developer
here at tasty but at home i'm a dad
and the chef on dinner duty my challenge
at home is to come up with ideas that
mom and dad love
and the kids enjoy so i've taken the
flavors of a french onion soup those
deeply caramelized onions beautiful
gruyere cheese
and combined them with a perfectly
cooked cheeseburger now the whole
process is something you could do at
home but it could get a little messy so
luckily i've got my sponge towels ultra
pro to help out
okay first things first we need to start
prepping our onions and getting them
cooking they take the longest but before
i start slicing and dicing
i'm not gonna do it on a wobbly board
that's a disaster waiting to happen so
let me show you a quick trick with my
paper towels to secure our board
all we're gonna do is get them nice and
wet
soak your paper towel and putting it
under our cutting board
will keep it nice and secure neat and
tidy right underneath
safe okay for the next hack apparently
if i soak
this paper towel in water one of our
producers swears
that my eyes won't water while i slice
onions this doesn't sound very
scientific to me but
let's try it out let's start prepping
our mountain of onions
so we're prepping eight to ten onions
which seems like a lot but trust me they
really cook down and get exaggerated in
flavor
and notice that i'm cutting them in half
so that i have a flat surface area once
i get to slicing
i don't want to slice a round onion that
could get a little precarious
i'm crying ah
these are happy tears we're gonna start
slicing this mountain onions i'm
tearing up we're gonna find out because
there's a lot more to slice now you can
see
i'm keeping it pretty thin it's gonna be
good we're gonna cook these
they'll be the most amazing jammy onion
topping on our burger happy tears
i've got my giant pot my mountain of
onions so to start we'll put in a little
bit olive oil
and some butter then a pinch of salt and
pepper the salt actually helps
release the moisture of the onions okay
so i'm on a medium low heat i want to
naturally release the sugars of the
onions so that they caramelize
low and slow i don't want to scorch them
this will take 60 minutes maybe even a
little bit longer so keep your eye on it
start from time to time
okay we started up here and now it's
cooked all the way down it's been just
over an hour and now to finish these off
i've killed the heat
we can go in with a little bit of sherry
vinegar give us that punch that acidity
to
counteract that that richness of the
burger and then umami some
worcestershire sauce
stir it in delish i'm gonna take this
off the heat and then we can form and
cook our burgers
for the burger part i want to keep it
super simple i've got good quality
ground beef i'm gonna form my patties
into a little ball and then
squeeze them down so that they're about
half an inch thick i always season my
burgers
right before cooking with a little salt
pepper i don't want the seasoning to
kind of draw out the moisture so always
season
right before cooking a little bit of
canola oil high smoke point oil
into the pan you can see right away it
starts to shimmer that means it's nice
and hot
and then i put my burgers in seasoned
side down
yes listen to that that's what you want
this is how i stay so young looking
beef steamed let's flip these bad boys
over
yes this is the crust that i want look
oh yeah
these burgers are looking great let's
take them off and then we'll cook the
other three
two to three minutes per side and then
we start assembling
we've got our onions we've got our
burgers i'm gonna whip up a quick mayo
now
i like a little bit of truffle paste in
my mail for that
luxurious kind of umami rich flavor
keep some plain mayo on the side for
your kids if they don't like any of that
so i've got my
beautiful brioche bun perfectly toasted
mayo
on each side look at the beautiful
truffle and really load it up
and then throw down my burger right on
there you top it with those caramelized
onions and then on top of those
beautiful onions
gruyere cheese that famous nutty french
cheese a little bit of arugula on the
top half
and you have got the most perfect
gourmet
french onion burger before i dig in let
me get this
great burger the messier the better
let's give it a shot oh yeah
the onions the truffle the meat the mess
is worth it the mess is totally
worth it this is your new burger recipe
at home
you know how at the end of all our
videos there's that guy who goes oh
yeah can i be that guy now oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yes